Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
NV Energy the sponsor of this next
segment provide energy services to
nearly 1.3 million customers that is
impressive what's even more impressive
is how much they give back to the Las
Vegas Community here to tell us more is
Tony Sanchez the Executive Vice
President of Business Development and
external relations welcome to the show
thank you JC let's break down what you
guys did on Martin Luther King Jr day
because this is very very special sure
the last 15 years our employees are very
very volunteer oriented and so as a
company we support you know different
organizations that they're involved in
and for 15 years now and this included
on Monday we had 100 employees that went
out to Three Square to pack backpacks
and family meal kits for folks that need
it during the week and so it's turned
into our biggest employee event it's the
most popular one in in our employees at
NV Energy all my colleagues really just
love giving back to the community and so
that's the favorite project and we see
you guys do that always giving back to
Las Vegas taking care of our community
how does it make you feel when you see
we have this program going on all of a
sudden 100 employees say we're here to
help we say we need to do a lot more of
those right I mean we tell our employees
if you want to serve on a board or you
want to be involved with the non-profit
you know let us know and we have a
foundation the Envy energy Foundation we
give out over 5 million dollars a year
from that throughout the state of Nevada
but we have you know events in obviously
Reno Las Vegas but we have 2 300
employees throughout the state and so we
a lot of those are in smaller
communities and so you know there's
virtually very little that we don't fund
we don't put all our money in one
particular non-profit or charity you
know we have to really spread it out
because we serve 90 percent of the state
of Nevada what was it about three Square
though for this for this event that
they're the guys you go with it just
it's three square has just been such a
phenomenal success and they supply all
the food banks all over the valley and
you know you really can get a lot done
in bulk right and so we can get 100
employees there and they spend all
morning packing those backpacks for
students at the Clark County School
District you know who sometimes don't
have enough food at home over the
weekends and so they give these to them
uh to take and but it also includes food
for families and so it's something they
care about it's something that we
support with our foundation and it's a
it's a win-win and it also is very you
know an apropos day considering Dr
Martin Luther King's you know Credo to
give back to your community and
everything you know everything that he
was always fighting for for racial
equity and absolutely and so that's it
really ties in nicely we were talking
before we started because I had asked
you is it mandatory that your employees
volunteer because some companies and
it's fantastic they say you need to do
10 hours a year is it mandatory for your
employees to volunteer it's not
mandatory but we certainly don't have a
lack of Interest yeah I mean everybody
just wants to do it and that's what I
love and I think that starts from the
top down and they see that and that's
why they're so eager and willing to help
they are Tony thank you so much for
joining us have a great weekend and Las
Vegas now